I love this series I've watched all the
episodes totally enjoyed it um Gene my
first question is for you you know the
graphic novel was kind of a jumping off
point
um for this show but the series itself
is actually quite different
um when it came to adapting the series
did you have any like must-have scenes
that you wanted in the TV show I I did I
don't think I had any must-have scenes I
had must have
um themes you know I I really I I did
not want the um the Journey of the main
character to be different so the journey
in the book is Jin is somebody who feels
deeply uncomfortable with himself right
and he has this deep insecurity that's
rooted in his own cultural identity and
throughout the story it's kind of about
how he makes peace with that by
befriending this kid who's an immigrant
and he's an immigrant from Asia and
later to revealed that he's actually an
immigrant from mythological Asia as
opposed to human Asia so that piece I
wanted there I wanted to be the same I
wanted that to be the spine and um as
long as that spine was kept I think I
mean it's just about trusting the the
people that you're working with right
when we and and I think we just really
trusted Kelvin Yu to to run with it and
I think he's uh now that I've really
gotten to know him and gotten to see how
he works I've come to really admire him
both as a person and as a Storyteller I
think he's just brilliant yeah for sure
I mean I think one of the biggest
changes that I noticed was the change
now in the TV show and Melvin I wanted
to talk to you a little bit about that
and why you guys made that change and
the thought process behind that
character well I think you know um the
cousin character in the book uh that
Gene has has always been a little bit
controversial right and
and he'll he can speak to this better
but it was his hesitation about adapting
the thing was uh connected to that so
you know in our conversations the three
of us about uh the adaptation of this
you know one of the things was early on
we decided we're going to move it into
2023 versus the big 80s 90s of the book
took place in and I think Calvin found a
really great way to do something that
was really timely as well as kind of
brilliant in terms of encapsulating you
know
uh these stereotypes and tropes that
like Gene and icer grew up watching
right like it's been a big source of
conflict for me just like I'm a huge fan
of John Hughes and John Hughes movies
but he's got long long dark dog which
it's not great right and you know and
you know if you culminate that with just
like you know uh the the cousin
character I just thought like the really
smart way is it is to attack it head on
you know
um and putting it into the show as like
an actor and and someone who's uh you
know had to play a problematic role
because of the lack of roles I think is
really interesting and that's something
that like you know I wish Kelvin were
here because he could talk directly
about that you know like the character
we have in the show is called pretty
Wong but he actually played a character
called prey gong in a show called
Popular that was very similar to I mean
that's where he drew it from so it's
um it it's a very sort of personal and
and I I I'll say it brilliant you know
change to it for the show yeah I think
it was a great I mean having key play
that character especially given his
history and his career I think was it
was a great you know sort of mind-milled
moment yeah and I also think this show
does a really great thing with like
bringing in Chinese mythology you know
like I don't I'm pretty sure most
American children did not grow up with
the idea of like someone but like I did
and getting to see like Wang ying and
like you know all the characters there
what was um why did you guys choose to
expand on that aspect of the story well
we needed to to fill out
um you know an eight episode season so
the book is only 200 pages long it
um it it has a beginning middle and end
and it's a finite story right and uh
with with television it's open-ended
it's kind of like a superhero series you
know a superhero monthly series is
open-ended so the television series is
open-ended because of that we needed
expanded uh Worlds the way Kelvin and
his team did that on Earth was by
putting shifting some of the focus onto
Jin's parents and the way they did it in
heaven was by bringing in characters
like Wang Ying who are part of the
original original Source material right
the part of the journey and and you know
I'll borrow something from Kelvin that
he said before uh strike happened which
was you know
Disney is sort of a great repository of
like you know mythological characters
from the West right um whether it be
snow white or Cinderella or just
whatever
um the story may be and it's also the
place of superheroes right Marvel you
know all that stuff and we thought it
would be a really good thing to do here
at Disney to bring forward
um Eastern mythological characters like
you like you just said it uh the three
of us grew up with this you know I grew
up watching it uh at my grandmother's
house and hearing them tell me stories
about it so it's really kind of a cool
opportunity and an honor to sort of like
add guanyin and all these characters to
like sort of the Disney
you know repository you know like great
mythological Heroes for you know uh kids
like my my daughter you know like it's
uh it's kind of a great thing and and
kids that are not Asian or Asian
American you know like yeah it's uh what
I'd love to take away is like you know
some kid in uh the middle of the country
is a big son with Kong fan now you know
I mean I have always been a being so big
so Kong fan because of the monkey so you
know
um but you know I just touching on that
I also was surprised by how much
Mandarin was spoken in this show I was
kind of expecting you know some peppered
in but it was very heavy Mandarin and
like I speak Mandarin so I can
understand it all fine but I was
surprised um can you talk about that
decision and you know why you guys chose
to do that we we had uh lots of
discussions early on about language you
know and especially about the early on
Telvin wanted to do an episode that was
set in Chinese heaven so what language
do Chinese have it and ultimately you
can't have Chinese Heaven speaking
English that doesn't make sense at all
yeah yeah and I think a lot of that
decision was driven by
um this this hope that American
audiences are ready for this I I think
they are right when you look at the
popularity of things
um squid games I think they are yeah
that's right yeah for sure I mean I love
that episode I was definitely expecting
it to be in English because everybody in
that cast spoke English but I'm glad
that it wasn't
um and I'm glad that everybody could
speak like understandable Mandarin which
is sometimes a problem when I watch TV
shows and you know it's Cantonese and
then it's Mandarin and they just say
blanket Chinese
um and just touching on the cast of this
show you know there are some big names
not just Michelle yo not just Kihei Quan
but like James Kong you've got Stephanie
Shu you've got Ronnie Chang coming in
and like of course shinhan as um as
Jin's dad can you talk about how you
guys got these people to sign on to this
project was it just like a no-brainer
for them or was there you know what was
the dialogue well I mean we uh the
Endeavor was to sort of make
um or build the Chinese the Asian
American All-Star Game you know both
behind and in front of the camera and
you know it starts out with really good
material starting with Gene then to
Kelvin and then you add Destin who just
picks up the phone and calls Michelle
you know and then you know after that I
I call keep on and call Daniel Wu and
they all talk and everybody just it's
like a you know it's like a dominoes
start falling you know and and you call
you call Ronnie who is a good friend of
mine and and you know when I the other
people show up you know when the when
the material is good so
um hats off to both Gene and Kelvin here
yeah definitely I mean Melvin's under
underselling his role he he well Melvin
has his way of making things happen that
I still have not quite figured out you
know he'll he'll call me and be like
Michelle Michelle yo is part of it I was
like what what's going on oh and he'll
be like oh I got I got Dustin Clinton to
read it I think he's gonna sign on what
yeah it does that happened over and over
again for the last two years
and just have her be a part of anything
you know I mean
um I want to thank you so guys so much
for speaking with me uh it's a great
series I can't wait for everybody to see
it and yeah just good luck on this
thanks so much it's really nice meeting
here